c'est le retour du rif ice l'application
qui mélange nos têtes avec celles
d'autres stars et on va commencer avec
le beau gosse aux mille mariage
regardez regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'entraîner samedi on a également alors
là attention les yeux les cherry on à
isabella tasks qui est oui et mini
ratage optique on a mis on a misé à
belles dents le corps emilie franchement
c'est la même si pour ces actifs pourris
kokomo dire regardez
[Musique]
et tes côtés
c'est qu'aucun rebelle et rayonner les
commandes
rooney compris qu'elle n'existe pas la
dame elle n'a pas compris qu'elle
n'existait pas après dos alors regardez
on à jean-michel mer qu'on a me en
travolta et petit moment sensuel avec
nicolas pernikoff économie dominique
wavre garder à portée
[Musique]
c'est bien bouteille ou dell ça nous
fait rire
regardez où vous avez angel dans
balances ton quoi colonnes
[Musique]
pour défendre à tout prix
bonne ambiance halloween
sinon alors gilles verdez toujours très
soft ambrus bruce lee brucy regarde
[Musique]
ouais
on a également connu khelifa bien au
lara fabian elle avait envie de chanter
fort apparaît comme d'hab c'est la même
de la manne
[Musique]
c'est la même
sauf que le visage de kelis et celui qui
marche le mieux avec tous les sens mais
dans les faits un produit fiscal un
visage qui va qui axa ce c'est
incroyable ce morphing c'est vrai gilles
cordesse considère notre notre belle
delphine on lui a fait aussi un petit
elle est en moyenne
regardez
[Musique]
sur sa patte gauche
c'est ça qu'on voit qu'on est vraiment
très chaud nous les chéris prenez vous
étonner mais non mr rené bonnet je
voulais alors rené attendait parce que
rené j'en ai chialé nous allécher
j'en ai chialé du rire venez voir dans
l'instant tiffany on vous amuse bien
vous allez peut-être pécho sur le
titanic regarder
il
[Musique]
ils ont pris les mêmes tenez regardez
notre voie là prenez regarder il est
temps jul là c'est fort bien meilleure
[Musique]
moi
m
[Musique]
le 12 mai les pandas ça et moi alors moi
franchement j'étais pas pour et ceux qui
ont voulu mettre en tony montana dans
scarface
oui si ta poitrine rouge mais sans brad
pitt aura pas vu la différence
vous attendez en faire mais c'est pas ça
marche pas mal
ouais c'est surtout dans la tête les
gestes à leeds